[Musik]
>> SALLY: Sarah,
>> SARAH: Was?
>> SALLY: heute ist dein Glückstag.
>> SARAH: Echt?
>> SALLY: Ja, wir sind bei "Wünsch Dir was".
Du darfst dir was wünschen.
Kochen, backen, süß, herzhaft, sauer, egal was.
>> SARAH: Einen Käsekuchen.
Aber
>> SALLY: Okay.
>> SARAH: wehe, du machst Mandarinen rein.
>> SALLY: Okay. Einen normalen Käsekuchen?
>> SARAH: Nee. Warte. Warte.
Ich nehme einen Peanutbutter Cheesecake.
>> SALLY: Okay. Geht es bitte euphorischer?
>> SALLY: Ein Peanutbutter Cheesecake!
Ah!
>> SALLY: Oh! Mit Schokolade oder ohne?
>> SARAH: Mit.
>> SALLY: Also ein...
>> SARAH: Obendrauf Schokolade
und obendrauf Erdnüsse
>> SALLY: Woah!
>> SARAH: und obendrauf kleine süße
Karamell-Schokoladenstücke.
>> SALLY: Uh!
Ich erfülle dir deinen Wunsch.
Es gibt einen Peanutbutter Chocolate Cheesecake.
>> SARAH: Danke. Du bist meine Traumfrau.
>> SALLY: Uh! Und du meine.
Hallo!
Herzlich willkommen zu Sallys Welt!
Heute gibt es ein Wunschrezept
von Sarah aus unserem Team.
Sie hat sich einen Peanutbutter Cheesecake gewünscht,
also auf Deutsch
einen Erdnussbutter-Schokoladen-Käsekuchen.
Und ich freue mich.
Denn ich glaube, der wird richtig lecker.
So einen habe ich echt so auch noch nicht gemacht.
Ich mache jetzt erst mal einen Schoko-Crunch-Boden.
Ich lehne das ganze so ein bisschen
an meinen New York Cheesecake an.
Denn der war schon unglaublich lecker.
Und dieser hier wird einfach mit Erdnüssen
und Schokolade verfeinert.
Ich glaube, das wird schon eine gute Kombi.
Ich mache erst mal den Crunch-Boden.
Dafür verwende ich
100 Gramm Butter,
50 Gramm Zartbitterschokolade,
50 Gramm gesalzene Erdnüsse
und 250 Gramm Kekse.
Da verwende ich jetzt Vollkornkekse.
Im Prinzip zuerst einmal
die Butter mit der Schokolade schmelzen.
Ich lasse jetzt erst die Butter schmelzen.
Nicht aufkochen lassen,
sondern wirklich bei geringer Hitze
schmelzen lassen.
Und dann werde ich die Schokolade dazu geben,
wenn der Herd schon wieder aus ist,
damit die nicht verbrennt.
Die kommt dann dazu.
Ihr könnt sie auch vorher zerkleinern, wenn ihr wollt.
Ich werde in der Zwischenzeit
aber schon mal hier die Kekse zerkleinern und die Nüsse.
Und da habe ich jetzt gesalzene Erdnüsse.
Denn da ist der Geschmack schon toll.
Also, wenn man das so miteinander kombiniert,
ist schon was Feines.
[Musik]
Die Erdnüsse, die lasse ich grobstückig.
Das ist gut.
[Musik]
Dann könnt ihr die Keksbrösel
gemeinsam mit den Erdnüssen
hier reingeben und vermischen.
Ich habe jetzt auch schon mal den Ofen vorgeheizt
auf 160°C Ober-/Unterhitze.
Wenn ihr möchtet,
könnt ihr hier auch schon Schokoladenkekse benutzen.
Ich muss aber sagen,
ich benutze hier auch echt ganz gerne die Vollkornkekse,
weil es einfach megagut dazu passt
und auch sehr, sehr gut schmeckt.
[Musik]
Jetzt guckt mal hier.
Die Masse sie noch ein bisschen trocken aus.
Also wären das jetzt normale Butterkekse
und keine Vollkornkekse,
würde die Butter schon ausreichen.
Ich gebe da jetzt aber noch einen Esslöffel Butter dazu,
damit es einfach ein bisschen feuchter auch wird
und homogener.
Und dann kann ich es nämlich hier reindrücken.
Also da bin ich aber auch mit der Buttermenge,
muss ich sagen, immer etwas vorsichtiger zuerst,
lieber nicht zu viel.
Denn ansonsten tritt das auch im Backofen später aus.
Das heißt, ich gebe das hier kurz drauf,
mache ein Stück Butter noch dazu
und kann das dann noch mal bei geringer Hitze schmelzen.
[Musik]
Diese Mischung kommt jetzt hier in den Backring.
Den habe ich bereits auf 24 cm eingestellt.
Ich habe eigentlich kurz überlegt,
den einzuschlagen in Backpapier,
dass nichts ausläuft.
Aber bei meinem New York Cheesecake
hatte ich es auch nicht eingeschlagen
und da ist auch nichts ausgelaufen.
Von daher, denke ich, sollte es passen.
Und jetzt schön flach drücken,
entweder mit der Hand, mit einem Glas
oder mit der Burgerpresse,
die ich halt echt häufiger zum Kuchenbacken benutze
als zum Burgermachen, muss man dazu sagen.
Aber es ist halt cool, weil man wirklich direkt
die ganze Menge flach bekommt.
Und ich meine: Wer hat schon ein Glas Wasser,
was so einen Durchmesser hat?
Oder?
Ich habe jetzt hier einen recht dicken Boden.
Also, wenn ihr sagt, nö, eher dünnerer Boden,
macht es dünner.
Aber ich finde es megacool.
Denn der schmeckt uns halt so gut.
[Musik]
Dann kann der Boden jetzt vorgebacken werden
für 15 Minuten.
Danach nehme ich ihn raus, lasse ihn abkühlen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit dann die Creme zubereiten.
Und ich nutze jetzt die Zeit, um uns ein Porridge zu machen.
[Musik]
Der Boden ist jetzt gebacken und auch abgekühlt.
Jetzt kann es direkt mit der Creme weitergehen.
Ich habe in der Zwischenzeit übrigens ein Porridge gemacht
und zwar ein Carrot Cake Porridge.
Also wie ein Karottenkuchen schmeckt das Frühstück.
Echt megalecker!
Ich habe euch das Rezept schon in die App gestellt.
Im Blog findet ihr es
und auch als Reel auf meinem Instagram-Account.
Genau, da findet ihr es.
Das esse ich jetzt gleich, wenn der Kuchen im Ofen ist.
Hier habe ich jetzt schon die Zutaten für die Creme.
Und zwar verwende ich dafür
700 Gramm Frischkäse,
100 Gramm Sahne,
250 Gramm Erdnussbutter,
150 Gramm Zucker
und fünf Eier.
Hier könnt ihr darauf achten,
dass die Zutaten relativ zimmerwarm sind.
Also das muss jetzt nicht mehr kalt sein.
Und ich habe jetzt hier 6 Eier drin.
Aber das sind kleine Eier.
Ich hatte nämlich nur noch S-Eier da.
Und da könnt ihr einfach euch immer grob merken:
Ein Ei der Größe M wiegt 50 Gramm.
Und deswegen habe ich jetzt hier ein sechstes dazu mit S
und habe es so ausgeglichen.
Ja, weil man ja nicht immer gleich große Eier kriegt.
Ist halt so.
So ist die Natur.
Gut.
Jetzt gebe ich den Frischkäse in die Rührschüssel.
Das Karottenkuchen-Porridge schmeckt übrigens
wie Karottenkuchen, der noch nicht gebacken wurde.
Und beim Porridge achte ich ja immer darauf,
bei unserem Haferbrei,
dass einfach
ich keinen industriellen Zucker mit dazu nehme.
Also entweder nehme ich dann Bananen
oder getrocknete Früchte zum Süßen.
Und das ist dann echt auch immer sehr, sehr gut.
Dann kurz verrühren.
Jetzt die Sahne dazu geben.
Jetzt darauf achten, dass es nicht schaumig gerührt wird,
sondern wirklich nur cremig,
also keine Luft einschlagen.
Das heißt, das Handrührgerät
nicht bei voller Einstellungsstufe laufen lassen,
sondern wirklich bei niedriger Stufe.
Und dann gebe ich jetzt gleich nach und nach den Zucker
und dann noch die Eier dazu.
[Musik]
Und dann
füllt ihr diese cremige Konsistenz
hier ein.
[Musik]
Dann schön verstreichen.
Dann backe ich den Kuchen jetzt bei gleicher Temperatur,
also bei 160°C Ober-/Unterhitze,
für 15 Minuten weiter,
stelle dann den Ofen auf 130°C runter
und backe ihn dann noch mal für etwa 45 bis 60 Minuten.
Das wird schon lecker.
[Musik]
Der Käsekuchen ist jetzt gebacken und abgekühlt.
Ich habe ihn jetzt noch in den Kühlschrank gestellt.
Und jetzt mache ich hier noch eine Schokoladen-Ganache,
nämlich aus Sahne.
Da nehme ich jetzt 100 Gramm.
Die lasse ich hier aufkochen
und kann in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
die Zartbitterschokolade fein hacken.
Da habe ich jetzt 200 Gramm.
[Musik]
Und, sobald die Sahne kocht, den Herd ausschalten,
die Schokolade einrühren
und so lange rühren, bis sich alles gut vermischt hat.
Und dann kann ich in der Zwischenzeit
schon mal ein paar Erdnüsse hacken.
Ja. Denn jetzt geht es direkt schon an die Deko.
[Musik]
Dann nehme ich schon mal meine Tortenplatte.
Jetzt könnt ihr den Kuchen platzieren
und die Folie drunter wegrollen.
Ui!
Hörst du den knusprigen Boden?
>> JOSH: O ja!
[Musik]
>> SALLY: Dann kann man hier noch so einmal drüberfahren.
Dann wird es auch schön glatt.
Ups!
So.
Und dann kommt das hier drauf.
Hm.
So hat sie sich das gewünscht, die Sarah.
Ich habe Schwarz auf Schwarz nicht gesehen.
[Musik]
Und jetzt könnt ihr
den Kuchen mit weiteren Zutaten dekorieren und fertigstellen.
Ich nehme auf jeden Fall gesalzene Erdnüsse.
Die werden ein bisschen gehackt.
Dann habe ich hier noch so Karamell-Schokoladendrops
und Kakaonips.
Ich glaube, das ist gut.
[Musik]
Da das Sarahs Wunschrezept war,
darf sie heute probieren.
>> SARAH: Hallo!
>> SALLY: Okay.
Sarah, sieht er so aus, wie du ihn dir vorgestellt hast?
>> SARAH: Ja, besser,
muss ich sagen.
>> SALLY: Und ich rede vom Käsekuchen.
>> SARAH: Cheesecake
>> SALLY: Vom Cheesecake.
>> SARAH: Peanutbutter Cheesecake.
>> SALLY: Der ist so richtig smooth.
>> SARAH: Oh, sieht der schön aus!
>> SALLY: Oh! Später das Foto,
dann schneiden wir noch so zwei, drei und dann...
>> SARAH: Hm. Hm.
Und dann so eine Gabel wie so...
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Oh, wow!
>> SALLY: Der ist auch noch nicht ganz kalt.
>> SARAH: Perfekt!
>> SALLY: Denn
– also den solltet ihr schon...
Na, also für die Schokomasse schon kalt werden lassen,
aber bei Raumtemperatur hat der halt so das beste Aroma.
>> SARAH: Einfach komplett aufessen,
während er Raumtemperatur hat.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Please.
>> SARAH: Er ist zu schön!
>> SALLY: Er ist echt schön.
>> SARAH: Gell?
Egal. Ich will ihn probieren.
Woah!
Geht es perfekter?
>> SALLY: Der ist schon...
>> SARAH: Es ist ein bisschen groß geworden.
>> SALLY: Dann dreh dich um.
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
Mmh!
>> SALLY & JOSH: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> JOSH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Mmh!
>> MURAT: Mmh!
Mmh!
>> SARAH: Mmh!
>> SALLY: Hm.
>> SARAH: Der ist schon çok güzel.
Habe ich überall?
Mmh!
>> SALLY: Der ist schon
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: sehr gut,
muss man schon...
Findest du ihn zu wenig süß?
>> SARAH: Mhm.
>> SALLY: Weil ich habe...
>> SARAH: Ich finde ihn eigentlich perfekt so.
Weil meistens sind die mir zu süß.
>> SALLY: Mir nämlich auch.
Weil ich habe im Vergleich zum New York Cheesecake
einfach weniger Zucker genommen,
weil mir der New York Cheesecake schon ein bisschen
>> SARAH: Hm.
>> SALLY: zu süß ist.
Aber den finde ich perfekt,
also echt gut.
>> SARAH: Davon kann man auch ein Stück essen
und ist danach nicht so
>> SALLY: Genau.
Ja.
>> SARAH: bam.
>> SALLY: Also dafür, dass es so ein
krass cremiger Peanutbutter Cheesecake ist,
finde ich ihn nicht schwer oder mächtig.
>> SARAH: Aber der ist megalecker.
>> SALLY: Der ist richtig gut.
Also ich muss sagen,
ich esse selten ein ganzes Stück Kuchen,
aber von dem esse ich eins.
>> SARAH: Hm, ich auch.
>> SALLY: O ja!
Und ich finde, wir sollten sowieso
eine komplette Cheesecake-Kategorie machen.
In Amerika gibt es doch die Cheesecake Factory.
Da waren wir mal, in Chicago.
Und ich sage es euch,
so lecker!
Also falls ihr Wünsche habt an Käsekuchen,
dann schreibt sie gerne...
>> SARAH: Wehe, du machst Mandarinen rein.
>> SALLY: Ich mache keine Mandarinen rein.
Nur der...
Nur der Kelvin mag Käsekuchen mit Mandarinen.
>> SARAH: Für mich ist das ein Verbrechen.
>> SALLY: Und dann frage ich in meinem Team
noch nach weiteren Rezeptwünschen,
dass jeder mal sein Rezept sich wünschen kann
und jeder hier verkosten kann.
Okay. Also es gibt dann weitere Team-Wunsch-Rezepte.
Viel Spaß beim Nachbacken!
Das Rezept gibt es in der App, in der Sallys Welt App,
– die ist kostenlos –
und auch im Blog.
Und ich freue mich schon auf eure Version.
>> SARAH: Er ist mega!
Danke!
>> SALLY: Du hast nicht gesungen.
Du wolltest singen.
>> SARAH: Ich habe es vergessen,
weil ich so excited war.
>> SALLY: Ja.
Guck mal. Zwei Stunden lang da hinten gesungen.
>> SARAH: Geübt.
>> SALLY: Geübt.
>> SARAH: Einen Tanz einstudiert.
Jetzt geht es nicht mehr.
Jetzt ist es zu spät.
>> SALLY: Mhm, so was muss spontan kommen.
>> SARAH: Hm.
Kann ich den mitnehmen?
>> SALLY: Ja.
>> SARAH: Gut.
>> SALLY: I'm so excited!
>> SARAH: And I just can't hide it!
[Musik]